d'habitude dans les tôles que tmx qu'on
cherche à faire
c'est une
une idée que l'on a personnellement mais
aujourd'hui j'ai plutôt essayé de vous
faire chercher à comprendre les idées
des autres
alors pour commencer quelqu'un que l'on
aime pas qu est ce qu on entend ici par
quelqu'un que l'on aime pas alors ça
peut être absolument n'importe qui ça
peut être quelqu'un que vous connaissez
très bien où quelqu'un que vous croisez
de manière très ponctuelle
peut-être quelqu'un que vous avez vus à
la télé quelqu'un qui a fait un talk
tedx que vous n'avez pas aimé c'est
peut-être quelqu'un que vous avez vus à
la télé non car soir ça peut être
quelqu'un qui est assis à côté de vous
en ce moment alors si c'est le cas vous
vous tapez pas dessus tout de suite
battant dès la fin ça pourra éviter
et ça peut être par exemple pour prendre
un exemple qui touchent quasiment tout
le monde puisque tout le monde il
presque doit avoir le permis et doit
déjà conduire une voiture qui pollue
énormément comme on l'a vu on a tous
toujours râler contre les personnes qui
n'avance pas sur la route et est ce que
vous êtes déjà demandé pourquoi est ce
que vous n'aimez pas ces personnes alors
partagés mais ces personnes on va
entendre par là qu'on ne va pas aimer
leurs actions leurs réactions leurs avis
et par exemple pour reprendre cet
exemple de la personne sur la route mais
généralement s'ils n'aiment pas cette
personne on a souvent une question qui
nous vient une question qui nous vient
une phrase un peu brutal qui nous vient
qui est parfois vulgaire là je vais la
faire non vulgairement
mais pourquoi elle n'avance pas et cette
phrase c'est en fait une phrase
interrogative compose avec un point
d'exclamation et ça c'est assez
révélateur de deux choses la première
c'est le pourquoi donc qui révèle une
incompréhension on ne comprend pas
pourquoi cette personne là elle n'avance
pas et la deuxième chose c'est le point
d'exclamation que le mais à la fin de
cette phase interrogative qui en fait
est assez significatif du fait qu' on
comprend pas pourquoi et on ne cherche
pas vraiment d'ailleurs à comprendre
pourquoi elle ne le fait pas donc pour
ça il n'ya pas 40 moyen de le savoir
donc par exemple quand c'est un jeune
conducteur ou quelqu'un quand au top
conduite accompagnée on est un macaron
en conduite accompagnée et vous verrez
quand vous avez vous retrouvé derrière
quelqu'un qui n'avance pas sur la route
et qu'un macaron conduite accompagnée
tout de suite ça vous énerve - il ya une
autre façon de comprendre la personne
c'est d'avoir été à sa place ou d'être à
sa place ça je l' ai compris un jour
quand j'étais donc j'étais en 18 rn6 et
j'étais en stage dans la vallée de
l'arve dans une
dans une industrie où on fabriquer des
barres de torsion c'est ce qu'on met
dans les boîtes de vitesses des voitures
donc c'est des toutes petites pièces en
fonte très lourde pris indépendamment
elles sont légères mais quand il y en a
plusieurs centaines ces traits loi et
donc je devais aller de lusine jusqu'à
un entrepôt situé à 30 km avec un
fourgon de l'entreprise et donc j'étais
jeune permis à l'époque je ne permit
roulant un peu vite
bien sûr il ya prescription maintenant
donc à l'aller je roule assez vite dans
les virages j'arrive à l'entrepôt les
caristes charge plusieurs bacs donc de
ces petites barres de torsion
il cherche son nom dans le fourgon en
question et puis je repars tambour
battant à fond vert
vers l'usiné sauf que malheureusement
premier rond-point tout se renverse un
bruit du diable derrière dans le coffre
donc je m'arrête je fonce derrière
j'ouvre la porte et là il y en a de
partout
donc je vous rappelle que je suis en
stage à ce moment là je suis un peu
flipper d'arriver à l'entreprise avec un
gros bordel dans le coffre
donc j'essaye rapidement de reprendre
toutes les barres de torsion et de
relever sauf que 300 barre de torsion ça
pèse plus de 30 40 kg donc j'y arrive
pas bref je panique je peux vous dire
que les 29 km restants que j'ai fait
pour aller à l'usiné les effets en
roulant tout doucement et je me suis
bien sûr pas fait que des copains sur
leur route mais maintenant quand je suis
un fourgon je me dis qu'il doit avoir
une bonne raison de rouler doucement et
ça m'apaise
mine de rien ça m'apaise alors tout ça
pour vous dire que les gens qui étaient
derrière moi à ce moment là et ils ont
dû donner des noms d'oiseaux pour rester
poli et quand on a des personnes qu'on
n'aime pas par ce genre de réaction
d'action que l'on ne comprend pas on a
tendance à les catégoriser à chaud très
rapidement ça peut être l'intolérant
parce que cette situation là on peut
extrapoler et l'appliquer dans plein de
situations c'est peut être l'intolérant
parlant de corte va parler
d'environnement de politique de social
ça peut être quelqu'un de stupide
on peut le qualifier aussi de stupide
parce qu'on ne trouve que ce qu'ils
disent est totalement bête parce qu'on
ne comprend pas pourquoi il dit ça ça
peut être aussi le pénible alors ça on
connaît tous celui là pour faire un
dessin on retrouve beaucoup dans
l'administratif le pénible
après si vous aux secrétaires ou quoi
généralement elle c'est un peu pénible
alors il faut savoir moi j'ai travaillé
dans l'administratif j'ai été le pénible
fin surtout par chance j'avais une
gestionnaire qui faisait les papiers et
qu'il est demandé aux chercheurs qui
était donc qu'ils avaient besoin de
papier
pour pouvoir être couverts lors de
missions qu'ils allaient réaliser sur le
terrain et donc il détestait aller voir
cette gestionnaire
parce qu'à chaque fois les bassines est
clairement elle passait pour la grosse
pénible et bien un jour j'ai trouvé la
solution je les ai simplement fait
discuter l'un et l'autre
les chercheurs ont demandé
on discutait avec la la gestione en
question et ils ont compris en fait que
la gestionnaire bas si elle demandait
tous ses papiers s'étaient pas pour les
embêter
c'était pas pour son plaisir au
contraire c'est qu'elle en était obligé
est alors à partir de là ils ont compris
en fait que la gestion c'est encore pire
pour elle cette gestion administrative
parce que c'était son travail il fait
vraiment officiel demandé tout ça c'est
parce que l on avait vraiment besoin
donc conséquence de cela les chercheurs
ont compris pourquoi est-ce que
gestionnaire leur demander tout ça et
ensuite leurs relations se sont apaisées
j'étais presque content après d'aller la
voir
donc vous l'aurez compris pour
solutionner bien nombre de conflits avec
des personnes que vous n'aimez pas où
vous ne pensez ne pas aimer à chaud il
faut discuter avec eux il faut engager
la conversation et je vous donne
quelques astuces pour faire en sorte que
cette discussion soit encore plus
productives la première j'aurais compris
discuter mais aussi écouter c'est
important de laisser l'autre parler pour
le comprendre
donc prenez le temps de les écouter la
deuxième un peu plus dur encore c'est
d'oublier votre avis personnel pour être
le plus objectif possible essayez quand
vous écoutez quelqu'un avec qui vous
n'êtes pas d'accord de l'écouter sans le
juger
sans chercher à contredire chaque phrase
qu'il va dire et donc être le plus
objectif possible pour
vraiment se mettre à sa place et
justement se mettre à sa place être
empathique
c'est la 3ème astuces que je peux vous
donner et essayer de vous projeter de
vous mettre vraiment à sa place et enfin
là c'est le plus dur c'est laisser de
côté son ego personnel et accepter aussi
que on a peut-être il ya d'autres
vérités alors ça ça marche pas vraiment
ça s'applique pas vraiment à l'exemple
de la voiture mais notamment en
politique ou en économie ou en social ce
sont des sciences qui sombre il peut
vraiment varié enfants alors vous vous
êtes plutôt technique ici donc il faut
que ça vous parle pas forcément mais il
faut aussi accepter qu'il ya d'autres
vérités et
et que bon on n'a pas forcément une
pensée unique et heureusement en france
en tout cas on est encore libre de
penser ce qu'on veut tant que ça on
enfin pas la liberté des autres
tout ça ça va vous procurer de nombreux
avantages le premier déjà c'est que vous
allez être apaisées pourquoi vous allez
être apaisé parce que quand on comprend
on accepte mieux
voilà l'exemple de la voiture c'est
celui qui vous parlera le mieux la
deuxième chose c'est que vous allez être
plus tolérants et que vous allez donc
mieux vouloir mieux pouvoir évoluer dans
le collectif et ça s'applique autant au
secteur professionnel que privé
si vous êtes dans le par exemple peut
être avec vos amis vos familles et c est
aussi dans la lettre dans les travaux
collectifs
alors j'imagine que là en tant
qu'étudiant vous je travaillais déjà sur
des projets collectifs et parfois quand
quelqu'un vous contredire bas essayez
plutôt de d'échanger tout de suite
plutôt que ça bout et que ça vous fait
que vous exploser ou un moment et vous
[ __ ] sur la tronche essayer d'en
parler tout de suite et puis apprendre à
prendre parce que parler avec des gens
qui pensent comme vous c'est bien ça
fait plaisir d'entendre les choses que
l'on pense et des gens qui sont d'accord
mais lorsque vous parlez avec des gens
qui ne partagent pas forcément vos avis
et bien c'est encore plus enrichissant
voilà si vous n'avez pas aimé ce talk je
vous invite du coup à venir en parler
avec moi et surtout n'oubliez pas de
parler aussi avec les gens que vous
aimez bien merci
[Applaudissements]